Jack Palance just bungee jumped off the
Hollywood sign
ah these kids today you know
little decaf jack by now back to reading
those of you in America probably used to
seeing these red ribbons that some of us
are wearing but for our global audience
I'd like to explain that they are worn
as a symbol of AIDS awareness and to
show our solidarity with the people who
are suffering from this epidemic and
with the people who are fighting every
day to wipe it off the face of our earth
and now a nominee last year for Best
Supporting Actress this year she not
only starred opposite Warren Beatty she
married him talk about improving his
seats ladies and gentlemen a great
actress miss Annette Bening
the film's nominated for art direction
this year ranged from the recreation of
times gone by to the creation of places
that never were all of the pictures
share a look that delights the eye and
enhances the experience of the movie
goer for art direction the nominees are
Barton Fink art direction by Dennis
Gassner set decoration by Nancy Hague
Bugsy art direction by Dennis Gassner
set decoration by Nancy hey the Fisher
King art direction by Mel Bourne second
decoration by Cindy Carr hook art
direction by Norman Garwood sec
decoration by Garrett Lewis the Prince
of tides our decoration by Paul silver
set decoration by carol hellar
and the Oscar goes to Dennis Gassner for
Bugsy and set decoration
Wow - okay I'd like to thank the Academy
Warren Beatty Vera Levinson Mark Johnson
Charles Charles new words for creating
such a wonderful film my art department
Leslie McDonald my art director art
department staff my my family my friends
and my wife Amy mess thank you I'd like
to thank my wonderful crew Robert
Greenfield and Paige and Claire and
Tinker and spell and Linda and Charlie
and a great prop master Jerry moss thank
you ladies and gentlemen here is the
all-time box-office championship
producer director Steven Spielberg